i have to play this because
rotc has gotten some new sponsors and
but guess what i guess so guess who got
a sponsor
day wave did so let me just play my
quick this this quick added so take a
second
not everyone is fortunate enough to know
my techniques
of how to make a lot of money the tom vu
method
differs from others in that his system
teaches you how to make money in real
estate immediately
and enjoy life right away i know some of
you are thinking
my seminar is the same like everybody
else seminar my seminar is not the same
like everybody else
my course is copyrighted it means no one
else is allowed to fix my unique course
plus my system can show you how to put
money in your pocket in real estate
right away that's look hey
i'm sorry you don't want to be a
millionaire because i know i do
and this i'm sorry let me ask you a
question do you think these women would
just be on a boat with this guy
if he wasn't loaded i don't think so
i don't [ __ ] think so of course plus
my system
can show you how to put money in your
pocket in real estate right away
tomvu says a key to making quick money
in real estate
is to know how to deal is to not pay
your taxes
if you don't pay your taxes that's more
money
in your pocket
which again i mean that's up
in real estate right away tomvu says a
key to making quick money in real estate
is to know how to deal in distressed
properties
he says you can locate like for example
like distressed properties like that
house right there
dad never hugged it dad never hugged it
that property's not happy
take advantage of it like you would a
woman
huh yeah you know i'm right money making
properties
that this house right here coke problem
and honestly if there was a house i
thought i had a coke problem it would be
this one
distressed property take advantage of it
like you would a family member or a
woman
every day this is another house i just
bought
it's worth five hundred thousand dollars
was it california because that house
probably like ten million dollars now
michael is right buy haunted houses
buy houses that are haunted they are
distressed
they are scared you could really lowball
them if the house is haunted
pay a hit man to commit a murder in a
house you want to buy
the people in the house will want to
move out because nobody wants to live in
the murder house
these are ways that you make money i'm
telling you
go to my seminar it's great if you go to
my seminar
you're really going to understand what
i'm doing and my seminar is not only
copyrighted
it's trademarked
so i'm like two times better than this
guy with a semen app
using my own technique i pay only 285
000.
i make 215 000 in this house that's a
lot of money
you can tell cause he's flashing the
money on the screen
oh i'm sorry uh losers you don't want to
make 215 000
an instant profit because i know i do
two hundred and fifteen thousand dollars
you can take ten trips around the world
send four or five of your kids ten trips
around the world
but i don't want do i have to do i have
to use the money for that
and question can it be a hot air balloon
i have a lot of questions for this guy
look i'm not doubting that it works okay
who am i to talk down to our new sponsor
but i'm just very just wondering if
there's rules attached to this money
to go to college or you can even buy a
rolls royce
whoa hey hey take my name out of your
[ __ ] mouth
do you hear me take my name out of your
mouth
i don't want to hear you ever mention my
name again do you understand me
do you understand me don't make me part
of your little [ __ ] scheme your
little pyramid scheme i don't want to be
a part of it
come to my seminar i show you how to
make all kind of money
seminar here's a secret for you to make
millions
i think he means millions
very simple learn how to do your first
real estate transaction
make a small profit and after that don't
quit
keep repeating the same successful
process many times over
oh that's all you got to do man it was
this i'm assuming by
how old this is this was made before the
uh market crash huh
yeah he's got babes of course he's got
babes he's loaded executed you don't
want to be in a boat with this hunk
look at this hunk come on
you become very wealthy here's another
example how easy it is you can make a
lot of money
take a look at this house my friend well
we're not friends
i don't like you to presume that we are
i never you don't even know i don't know
your last name
it's worth 500 000 i pick it up for 285
000
making two hundred and fifteen thousand
dollars profit if you can do it
wow it's funny he always makes exactly
two hundred and fifteen thousand dollar
profit it's
really like he always makes that exact
amount of profit in all his properties
because he knows what he's doing
about ten deals like this the way i'm
about to show you you can retire
multi-millionaire
wow i can't wait to be multi-millionaire
people say that i'm a genius but i'm not
smarter than anybody
i don't think you're a genius i'm only a
lucky boy
who found a genius money making system
in the last
five years many of my seminar students
have applied my system and also make a
lot of money
let me take you through uh make a rotter
money this is i think what he meant to
say
an actual real estate closing where you
will see
one of my students apply my technique
about to walk away it's tech leak
oh this video everything about this is
amazing hold on real estate closing
where you will see one of my students
apply my technique
about to walk away with a nice check
walk away um this gentleman here and i'm
sorry because i know it's cutting it off
so you got to see the full beauty of his
hair
um this gentleman here is about to walk
away
with a big profit okay you don't want to
be that guy
you don't want to one day be the [ __ ]
mayor of chicago lori lightfoot looking
ass over here
profit
i invite you to come to my seminar learn
how to make a lot of money
once you have a taste of a good life you
will never go back
i did i'm not gonna go back
uh oh because i'm not gonna hang out
with all these babes of course listen
i've already bought the seminar
i just kind of need to find a vcr is
there a vcr i could borrow
pessy probably has a vcr pessy seems
like the kind of person that would have
a vcr
pesky you have a vcr right be honest
pessy has a vcrm positive nothing
less than nothing in just a few years i
made a fortune
i have everything i ever wanted you can
do the same thing
too if you know my technique to make a
fortune you don't need a credit
you don't need money you don't even need
a college degree to get started
if you have a desire get the guts come
to my seminar i have desire and i have
the guts have all those things let me
show you how
i know lots of you out there
[Music]
oh this video can't get any better uh
yes
it sure the [ __ ] can
it sure the [ __ ] can
this guy definitely kill somebody in his
home country
let me show you how i know lots of you
out there are skeptical
in my hand framed is a check for two
hundred and three thousand dollars
entry and twenty nine dollars and 32
cents
i net in one transaction
hold on i'm gonna clean a copy down the
banking number and routing number that
we could steal this person's money
one deal this is a net check i know
after watching me and my student making
a lot of money
you got excited and you want to go to my
seminar to learn how to i am
so i'm i'm i am
jesse spano levels of excited right now
i'm so
excited i'm so excited
macmillan's yourself and a lot of your
friends will tell you don't come to the
seminar
it's a get rich quick plan but tell them
it is a scheme
it's not get rich planets it's a scheme
get rich quick scheme
scheme is what you're thinking get rich
quick plan because life is too short to
get rid slow
if someone trying to discourage you my
friend take a look at them from head to
toe
if they are nothing stay away from them
you want to learn from success
not failure this th this guy just keeps
all his checks um
he didn't frame these these are not the
checks he framed
you see these chicks in my hands yes
okay you're being very very aggressive
right now
i do see the checks in your hand it
literally says official check at the top
why would they be lying to me i don't
think so
i don't want any problems bud i believe
you
i believe that you made this money
you know i did it the fact is lots of
people are making money all over the
country
starting with nothing very
very aggressive this guy seems like a
far cry villain it's making me
uncomfortable
if you don't know how the seminar will
show you exactly how
i never forget what my grandfather told
me there are two kind of people in life
the doer and black people he was very
racist
and the loser which one are you are you
sick and tired of where you are
working hard for years yes i'm so tired
of it
nothing are you excited about watching
my student making a fortune on tv
you know many of these people started
out with little or no cash and no credit
no experience
do you have a guts to step out of where
you are to achieve your financial
freedom
not really no it seems like a lot of
work
then come to my three hours success and
real estate investing seminar
the cover charge for this seminar is not
a thousand dollars it's not even 500
it's not even one hundred dollars the
curve of charge my friend is free
free and if you're not willing to spend
three three hours to learn from a
self-made millionaire to maximize your
opportunity
you deserve to be broke whoa
what a f wow now that's a hard sell
that is a hard sell you deserve to be
broke
did you hear him did you hear him guys
you deserve to be broke
that's a hard sell
jesus christ with this guy i don't know
i
shouldn't have taken him on as a sponsor
what's his name
tom vu
it seems like an old commercial wonder
is tom vu alive maybe he is let's see
tombu 2020
no i only found the knowledge you will
learn at my seminar
will make you financially independent
for the rest of your life
one of my recent transactions i walked
away with h i'm sorry sir
but is there a reason that your hair
looks like a skate ramp
do kids walk up and want to do sick
ollies off of your haircut
check for fifteen thousand ten dollars
and fifty cents
i took the tomboo prophet seminar
when i look at this guy and i'm sure you
guys agree
when i look at this guy all i think of
is success
all i think of his success when i look
at this guy
he is just a success magnet
it has worked for me it has made me
financially secure
you can do it too you don't have to ask
your boss for a raise anymore
you can give yourself the best raise of
your life come to my seminar
using the tom vu techniques i bought
this house made thirty three thousand
dollars
if i can apply the tomboo techniques and
make thirty three thousand dollars on
this house
you can do it too not only is this guy
an amazing actor but he's a millionaire
who doesn't want to be like this guy
another man that i look at and i go that
is success
that is that is a that is a successful
man
the money making strategy taught at my
seminar is the solution for those of you
who work hard
but are underpaid using the tomboo
technique
one of the homes i recently bought made
me twelve thousand dollars
and then i killed a woman in it and
she's buried in my basement
of that very home you don't need to be
look at these babes butts hey women
what's stopping you from wearing bikinis
like that again
oh it's not the 80s bring it back
bring it back why aren't you wearing
bikinis like that i'll start dressing
like this dude if you guys want that'll
be fair
i'll start dressing like him you ladies
bring back the
very high hipped bikinis and we all
party on boats
oh i'm sorry you guys want to party on
boats i told you the beginning of the
show this is a lifestyle i wasn't lying
to you this is the lifestyle
just beautiful flat asses
on a boat who doesn't want some
absolutely
listen you want to know you're
successful hang out with babes that
asses look like cutting boards
that is how you know that you're being
successful
genius to learn how to make a lot of
money with my system a lot of my
students who are average people
make a lot of money why not you can
average people make money this is the
house we just bought
it appraised for 98 000 and we were able
to get it for 55.
what this has done has given me
confidence in myself
that i know i have the ability to be
able to do this
he has confidence in me too but my
husband did all the work so all the
money is technically his
he left me for a young flat ass woman
and now he's also on a boat
so i'm kind of by myself uh we signed a
contract to this commercial but
technically we're divorced
at first i didn't feel that deals like
this were possible
but we have the house well look at my
haircut so i know what i'm doing
that's right i walked into the barber
shop and i'm like give me the lloyd
christmas haircut
and they said i got you fam
my barber is black and we have our
thirty thousand dollar profit
and i certainly believe now do you see
yourself a millionaire someday
have some guts make a decision come to
my seminar
all right all right i'll come to your
seminar
you sold me i mean i'm assuming you're
not doing them anymore
uh he's in orlando florida he's still
alive
he's made top 10 in the world series of
poker
is that really what he does now